c'est pas un discours politique un
sketch c'est pas un discours politique
faut pas le prendre aux prises la lettre
au premier degré sinon tu peux plus rien
dire chloé ste on va nous dire on va
mettre des caméras dans les bars et
quand les potes ils vont se retrouver
qui vont dire des conneries machin et où
habitait on va aller chercher
effectivement la parole qui est pas
acceptable mais on s'en sort plus où ça
commence où ça finit alors évidemment
que je préfère l'humour qui n'est pas
blessants pour tout un chacun qui n'est
pas vexant pour tout achat que moi
d'ailleurs de que tu nous avais dit de
regarder un skate qui moi le sketch de
gad elmaleh sur les trois religions
il me fait marrer parce que il parle
trois religions il n'est pas dans
l'obsession d'une religion comme
certains jumeaux les humoristes il ya
des humoristes qui prennent un angle et
le lâchez jamais mais c'est plus de
l'humour ça devient presque de la
gestion fruit de l'acharnement
donc ça c'est déjà c'est pas très clair
mais là il avait pris les trois
religions et puis il ne l'avait pas fait
avec un côté mesquin pour blesser on là
c'était plutôt c'était c'était
sympathique regarde c'était rigolo
regardez gad elmaleh s'étonnant les
religions d'ailleurs dans une église
tu dois te découvrir la tête dans une
synagogue découvrir la terre
mosquées dans les villes et ses cieux je
sais pas comment se sont organisés des
religions entre ils ont dû faire une
réunion à mon avis il ya longtemps avec
un responsable qui a du bon les gars
voulaient quoi les musulmans knoderer
trenque et le patch sur un tapis de saab
marque le lac d'incroyables merci
beaucoup
ok pas vous mais je vais vous voulez
quoi nous mais nous un truc sur la tête
fashion ambiance non pas ce tissu orange
il est bidon mais moins beaux tissus il
est conduit à ok c'est réglé avant les
catholiques
vous voulez quoi aurons-nous c'est comme
vous voulez à partir du moment où il ya
un petit coup à boire à des chips dire
sa life et les trois c'est vrai que ça
fait d'être apc sympathy ses arguments
il fait les trois rôles mais c'est trop
bien mais à ce moment c'est du talent et
en plus ils le font ces personnes ont
des limites et les lacs thomas y pointe
certains caractéristiques de certaines
religions et ils ont joué c'est drôle et
c'est là le talent de gad elmaleh à ce
moment là c'est de faire rire et de pas
blessé